and one of the lawmakers who visited the
border today republican new york
congressman john catko
he's also the ranking member on the
homeland security committee sir
thank you for coming on today your
colleague the house minority leader
kevin mccarthy calls this a
human tragedy would you agree with that
assessment and what did you see
on the tour well there's no question
it's a human tragedy and it's a tragedy
that didn't have to happen
when you get people in desperate
situations false hope
this is what happens and uh the
president has given him false hope by
signaling that he's going to relax the
immigration standards and
the people the big winners in this whole
thing are the coyotes and the drug
trafficking organizations
that are smuggling these people to the
border and what i saw today confirmed
everything
i already believe and that the disorder
at the border was caused by biden's
executive order
there's just no question about that and
we went up to what they call the
monument three which is intersection of
texas uh new mexico and uh
uh and mexico and when i was standing up
there looking out i was talking
about talking to one of the agents and
he's and he said the night before 100
agents had come across
and uh they said some of them are on the
list and i said what list
said the terror watch list and that
really sent my antenna up so it's not
just people come from honduras
come from all over the world they're
starting to exploit this gigantic gap in
our system and it doesn't have to be
yeah and yet the speaker of the house
says this is trump's fault watch her and
i'll get your response
on the other side congressman this is a
humanitarian challenge
to all of us what the administration has
inherited is a broken
system at the border and they are
working to correct that
in the children's interests congressman
does anybody believe that i mean the
mexican
president doesn't even believe that what
are your thoughts on speaker pelosi's
comment
boy i tell you that's that's max of
desperation but what was going on before
president biden took over was that the
the surge at the border had ended
people were discouraged from coming to
the border and they were encouraged to
come into this country the right way
and that's what that was working and as
soon as you change that
yeah you have people exploiting that
once again and not only are they
taking pr people coming across that
shouldn't be coming across some record
numbers because of
the because of biden's comments but
they're also taking people that were
called them remain in mexico policy to
stay in mexico until their asylum cases
are heard
and let them come into the country and
here's a fact i learned today speaking
of border patrol agents
once you let someone out into this
country that's here illegally and you
give them a court date and tell them to
come back
99 of them never come back
you know it's amazing to me because even
the left is framing this whole
crisis differently than what they did
back in 2019
you know it was kids in cages you
remember that vividly back in 2019 it
was kids in cages
over and over again and now you have cna
cnn saying things like
these are jail-like facilities these
children are involved in you know
speaker mccarthy's our
leader former minority leader mccarthy
said hey listen these kids are being
treated well
but this is not the best situation for
them at the border
it's not and i can't imagine the
desperation parents must have
to bring their children to the border
and send them across and you should put
a piece of tape under
on their shirt with some instructions
whatever because that's what the cartel
level
tells them to do but my god this is nuts
and 120 uh
border patrol agents were taken off the
border to deal with the individual the
unaccompanied children in the in these
facilities
and we already learned today that
they're at max so that means more
border patrol agents are going to come
off the border make our country less
safe
and now we know people even on the
terror watch list people from yemen
and the middle east are coming across
the border now so we are we are really
really have a time time problem here
for sure yep congressman katco thank you
for joining us sir we appreciate it
thanks so much